in my initial video I mostly talked
about the shape of water being a Hellboy
spin-off or a Creature from the Black
Lagoon sequel there were all kinds of
other ideas being presented and I love
seeing those intelligent discussions
taking place in my comments so here are
some of those theories many of you were
reminded of HP Lovecraft creation of the
deep wounds from Dagon and shadow over
Innsmouth I'm not much of a Lovecraft
expert so I looked it up on HP Lovecraft
wiki which basically said that there and
Wehling humanoid fish people with an
affinity for mating with humans some of
their physical traits include as small
years glassy bulging eyes hairless heads
webbed fingers folds on the neck which
become gills and rigid scales on the
back knowing that I'd say there's a very
good chance that del Toro was inspired
by Lovecraft on this one but the
question becomes was he inspired
directly there's been a bit of
controversy about the shape of water in
the indie film world because of how
similar the movie seems to be to this
2015 short film the space between us
with many of you making accusations of
plagiarism saying he took the concept of
the themes and look directly from the
space between us so I watched the short
film which is written and directed by
Dutch filmmaker mark s November and I
if this is plagiarism they didn't try to
hide it the main character is a cleaning
lady at some kind of secret lab facility
the space between us is about a post-war
era where oxygen is scarce and people
want gills so they can take advantage of
the oxygen underwater so these
scientists are developing this fish
person so they can give its gills to
their leader or whoever this person is I
need you skills tonight where as in the
shape of water scientists are developing
the fish man and some sort of weapon for
the Cold War the place where the
subjects are stored is a high-security
area they are stored in these vertical
water tanks with glass windows and the
people in charge seem to have sinister
plans for their specimen the fishermen
themselves are black and blue humanoid
creatures the one in the shape of water
has webbed feet while this one has a
more traditional mermaid tail they don't
like being locked up and the main girl
sets them free and sneaks them out of
the facility
the cinematography is similar the sound
design is similar from what we can sell
so far even some of the shots seem to be
almost identical
so did guillermo del toro rip off this
film maybe but I don't think there's
enough information to convict him del
Toro claims to have been developing the
film since 2011 which means nothing I
mean he could be trying to cover up his
plagiarism with that statement but it
does take at least a couple of years to
develop a complex feature film like this
the space between us was successfully
crowdfunded in August 2015 but was first
announced in late 2014 the strange thing
is while the indie film community has
raised this issue the director Marc
Knoll Kemper has been silent on it he
doesn't exactly have much social media
presence but they do have a website and
Facebook page for the film and the
similarities to the shape of water have
not been brought up
there haven't been any writing credits
signaling that the shape of water is
based on the space between us the only
person from either film who has even
acknowledged this is the production
designer from the indie film who just
says that del Toro's picture seems to be
inspired by their short
he doesn't seem mad about it even just
kind of proud of it I guess there could
also be a contract going on behind the
scenes so until the director comes out
and cries foul I don't see how I can get
too upset about it definitely suspicious
how similar these films are though but
there's one more possible connection I
was skeptical about it at first but the
commenters have raised some good points
I asked in the previous video about the
significance of the shoes that they keep
putting emphasis on in the trailer and
some of you thought it might be a
reference to the Little Mermaid only the
roles would be reversed to where the
male is the fish person instead in the
trailer she's referred to as the
princess without a voice just as Ariel
gives up her voice in the Little Mermaid
to go on land the significance of her
giving up her shoes could also be her
giving up her former life on lands to go
be with the fish person underwater James
Heskett points out that her shoe falls
off during the scene where she kisses or
dreams of kissing the fish man
representing her letting go of her ties
to her life on lands to find her love
below the surface Skylar has another
idea about the shoe symbol explaining
that the zodiac sign Pisces is the sign
of the fish Pisces rules the feet so
shoes will probably symbolically tie
into that Pisces is also known as being
a sign of dreams and escapism among
other things he wasn't the only one to
point out instances of symbolism that I
missed in the trailer
Brendon Remo suggested the fact that
she's a cleaning lady could have
something to do with her clearing the
evidence after she steals and hides of
the specimen later in the film maybe
some of the evidence she cleans up could
be this blood handprint on the theatre I
talked about this possibly being from
the creature attacking someone and
getting blood on his hands but it's also
been suggested that it could come from
Shannon since we see his hand wrapped up
in another shot I still think it's more
likely a handprint from the creature
since it is stated that he's a dangerous
animal but that's really just my gut
feeling I also talked about the bathtub
full of AVX but Mitchell Baldwin points
out
there's a strange substance in the tub
floating around and the same can be seen
in the creatures - Hank at the lab my
guess is that it's some kind of solution
that helps the creature in some way so
when Eliza sneaks the creature out of
the lab she also steals that solution so
the fish man can survive in her tub
until she figures out a better solution
for him there were a couple things I got
wrong in my other video like when I said
this could be a tentacle of some kind
looking at the other shots in the
sequence it makes more sense that this
is just a curtain or blanket in the room
I also said that the voice could be Doug
Jones but I wasn't really sure if I told
you about her
the princess without voice it seems that
it's actually Richard Jenkins who may
play a father figure - Eliza and then
there's the song which I brought up as
something in the style of classical
music which was another piece of
evidence towards this Fishman being
related to apes appian I'll touch more
on that later
but what I had said was that this movie
was pulling the baz lurman because the
recording was actually released in six
what I didn't realize was that this
version was actually a cover the song
has been covered forever throughout
history so it actually fits just fine in
a historical context I predicted that
some of the scenes in the trailer may
actually be dreams and this girl took it
a step further by saying that if the
subject does really have these psychic
abilities he may be the one causing
Eliza to have these dreams with his
powers and speaking of powers many of
you brought up the scene in the trailer
where Eliza looks to be controlling some
water droplets on the window I didn't
think much of it before because I
assumed she was in the lab the camera
right here is inside of the water tank
and those were just some bubbles that
she was pointing to it wasn't until I
saw a comment referring to this as the
bus window scene when I noticed that she
is in fact inside of a vehicle as
evidenced by the reflection of the
traffic lights so she is actually
controlling these raindrops with some
kind of telekinetic power perhaps
something she learned from the creature
and definitely more evidence that a
psychic connection does exist in this
movie and with that it's impossible not
to think about Abe Sapien let's just for
a moment set aside our views on if this
creature is related to Hellboy in any
and give him the benefit of the doubt
for a moment there are obviously some
differences in the design of Abe Sapien
from Hellboy 1 and 2 compared to the
shape of water creature but one person
pointed out that this new creature could
actually be based on the design from the
BPRD hell on earth comics which look
much more similar to the shape of waters
monster this guy on the other hand
mentions the new creature is blue just
like del Toro Wow a Pitt sniper you know
I never noticed this before but you know
actually his blue isn't he I'm so glad
that you pointed that oh ok I'm done I'm
absolutely done but on a more serious
note maybe this man near the end of the
trailer is a recast professor broom
probably the most popular comment that I
got though were the comments about Eliza
and the fish man creature being AIDS a
beans parents or grandparents and I
think it's reasonable to say that this
creature is of the same species as Abe
but if you look at the timeline of
events there's no way that Abe is their
descendant because Abe had already been
discovered about a hundred years before
the shape of water takes place some of
you also discussed that Fox Searchlight
probably doesn't have the rights to make
a new Hellboy movie and I think this
comment perfectly sums up my views on
the subject referring to an interview
with Guillermo years ago you did state
that the fantasy world in his films does
loosely have a connection legally he
wouldn't be able to make a Hellboy flick
but from an artistic point of view he
could make a movie closely resembling
the characters in the Hellboy franchise
as many movies have done and gotten away
with in that scenario he could albeit
make every little detail point towards
being a prequel without actually saying
that it is as long as they don't
explicitly state any names locations or
details he could imply a loose
connection if this is the case that
would explain why Guillermo del Toro and
Doc Jones have to deny any connection to
the hell bought universe in interviews
especially with a new Hellboy reboot on
the horizon and I think that's as much
as we'll see in the shape of water
the creature is just another organism
from the same species as Abe the title
of the movie is a perfect analogy for
the relationship it has to Hellboy the
film is called the shape of water water
molecules are fluid they don't have
anyone to find shape the movie won't be
shaped as
boy movie it won't have any of those
characters names or plot points but this
will just be its own movie composed of
the familiar materials that make up a be
Sabian they'll just be taking on a new
shape scary story narrations are also
taking on a new shape in the new true
horror game for mobile phones my friend
and fellow narrator let's read just
launched his game for Android and iOS
that lets you choose your own horror
adventure it comes with 10 stories and
is totally ad free I'll leave a link to
the download in the description next
week the shape of water comes out and
you'll definitely want to see my things
you missed where I'll be going in a
detail on it so remember to subscribe to
see ZZZ world for new Horrors every week
ring that death bell for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive